Here, the ranges were from negative infinity to negative 5, with the union of
negative 1 to positive infinity. Great work if you found these two intervals.
First, we want to find the values of p that make this equation true. We factor
to find the series of p and we get p is equal to negative 5, and p is equal to
negative 1. We use the values of negative 5 and negative 1 to create the three
intervals on our number line. For the first interval, I'm going to test the
value of negative 10. When I plug in at negative 10 for p, I'll get the
statement 45 is greater than 0. I know this is true so I can include it, this
part or this interval, in my solution set. For interval II, I'll plug in the
value p equals negative 3. When we substitute this value in, we get the
inequality negative 4 is greater than 0. We know this is not true, so we can
include this interval in our solution set. And finally, for the third interval,
we'll use the value p equals zero. If p equals zero, we lose these two terms
and are left with a statement 5 is greater than zero, which we know is true.
We'll use parentheses at negative 5 and negative 1, since we don't have the or
equal to symbol here. So any value, from negative infinity to negative 5 or any
value from negative 1 to positive infinity will satisfy our original
inequality. Here's our answer on a number line, and here's our answer written
in interval notation.